for since we were on the topic of fruits
you know how last time when I was here I
said I wanted to bring fruit as like
gifts yeah you didn't I brought fruit
this time oh hell yeah I'll take I'll
take Corners might change his opinion
wait no wait hold on let it cook could
be a banana
you could do it on the board hold up
hold up hold up listen listen okay I I'm
being
hyperbolic in a sense when I'm saying I
don't uh like any fruit but there's just
a lot of the time I just prefer vegan
oranges that would be if you give me a
[__] orange though are you a devil
okay they don't they don't unfortunately
I don't think luxury bananas are a thing
oh I don't I don't think there are
things they're not exactly the most like
High Class A bunch of dolls
bananas so I just got the most expensive
one that they had which was like which
was like 240 Yen hey hey still the cats
you know I appreciate that he's getting
Valley for his money I am I'm getting
value for money
Joey I know your favorite's watermelon
but watermelon is not in season yeah
unfortunately I don't know do you like
these whatever these
you do yeah what is that it looks
tumorous that looks like
um orange on steroids that isn't that is
a roided orange
that's me like my two boys when I leave
the answer that's what they look like
yeah so these are decoupon which are
like a type of uh Orange it's like a
it's like an orange uh Mandarin that's
just like the [__] liver King if he
wasn't orange
[__] yeah you know I'm always loving
strawberries who the favorite friend is
yeah
my fellow lamb haters where you are not
only did you get strawberries you also
got the the luxurious yeah
that's just bomb the the the white ones
yeah they're pretty they came in like
sets only in Japan they were like let's
make our strawberries anemic
I've always been curious because I've
always wondered what yeah thank you
thank you very much yeah why do you love
strawberries so much because one of the
first match
because because when we first met I
remember you saying oh yeah I like
strawberries I'm like I like
strawberries too but then like I cut
like slowly over the 10 months do I
realize oh you really like it was like I
like like strawberries you know that
Meme of like that's like the one with
the dudes like mem on one thing and it's
disgusting this is strawberries for
Emily you're playing with one thing and
it's disgusting oh my God the strawberry
bag
it's a very very cute bag it's from the
artist Nina fresas on Twitter
you also have the other variations you
have two of those I do I got I got one
strawberry version yeah
one for a different day yeah so yeah so
why do you love it everything about it
it's just it's it's beautiful I love the
look of it I love how they taste like
strawberries have always been like my
number one favorite fruit for the
longest time but then like I don't know
you see strawberry printed stuff and
it's like the cutest it is pretty cute I
think aesthetically they're they're very
nice did you survive yeah okay okay yeah
like I I do like the look of
strawberries but like I feel like
individually they are pretty usually
like the dolphins of fruit yeah like
they're like the most loved and most
revered and they look pretty and they
yeah they're kind of nice like you look
at a strawberry cake and you're like oh
that is so beautiful it's probably out
of the fruit Kingdom it's probably the
cutest fruit it is it is I think out of
like
in the food Kingdom it very much gels
with Japanese kind of like Japanese
culture as well right you can you can
have expensive looking strawberries you
can have small adorable smaller yeah
yeah exactly the Giga chatter because it
doesn't care it's got its own packaging
I hit it with the [__] did you when
you're in Thailand did you try any Thai
bananas I thought what the little ones
the little ones yeah I tried it it was
nice I think I prefer these though I
like I like the little ones
it's like bite sizes to me that's the
perfect size banana yeah this is the
goat he likes the thicker and girthier
than he does the Shelf package they
don't break easily they come in a bunch
I'm just thinking is there any fruit is
there any fruit that's more aesthetic
than a strawberry uh I mean there's lots
of Aesthetics fruits out there but they
don't taste very good I mean it's good
you know it reminds you of a box it's
kind of nice you know I just not they're
the it's they're the prettiest I mean
people like these melons do look cool
yeah the one when they're all like
perfect and they have all the you buddy
middle yeah yeah yeah yeah what about
like the way I'm paying like what about
the uh Japanese like square watermelons
have you seen those yeah I've never seen
one yeah I've seen them and I've have
had one before
do you know how they make them is it
like a special breed do they
specifically make them grow yeah
and they grow it in a box yeah and then
it it fills out I don't know who figured
this out that you could do this why have
we done this with bananas why have we
not done this with like more fruit
these were Square they'd be so much
easier to like I just realized it's a
[__] dance like why don't they do
super honest because it [__] grows on
a tree
I'll put the Box on the thing just hang
a bunch of boxes like it would be like
Minecraft already at the most like
Optimal [__] yeah it is perfect I just
wish that it you could like put it in
like a shelf and you can just
like opening a banana is the most fun
opening of any fruit
s
take this stupid [__] off but honestly
like yes
I appreciate that you can hold the
container and go as you like and peel as
much as you want to eat that's just
great it is the most optimized food it
is the most optimized fruit to be fair
fun we're having fun
did you know for most of my life I
actually opened Bernard I hated opening
bananas because I did this this is like
this like my something went wrong with
my childhood clearly somewhere uh
because for some reason my childhood my
child brain was like oh you open it from
this side you must open it from this
side because this is this is where the
gunk is so they give you a handle yeah I
know I know no no I realize that okay
okay all right all right all right okay
okay wow all right you think
you think you open it from here
this is
when I learned that we are [__]
stupid we go for the handle like this
okay monkeys open banana no they just do
this they just squeeze like that
oh that's that's actually how you
supposed to open a book you just
squeezed that that's what the monkeys do
and I realized when I first saw that I
was like God damn it that's why that's
why they know it that's why that's why
they're the best animals isn't it just
as fast to pull it no no try it do do
this fast as I do I don't want to eat it
I'll eat it
that's actually how I used to open them
that was lucky that was lucky
sometimes it makes dude it was this is
the best no this is the best this is the
optimizer why do you think the monkeys
do it they don't [__] around with the
top is it also because they don't have
thumbs yeah it smells good it does yeah
because okay this is all three this is
I mean okay never mind oh cheers
I mean oh goodbye not really yeah really
I mean I I feel like they've they are
exactly the same Technique No no no
because like when when you start off
with this end you get like the little
Gunk no no it's fine because sometimes
you do it from the top right and
sometimes it doesn't it doesn't break
perfectly and then it's like oh [__] no
if it doesn't break perfectly then I
know the banana is like
how nice no you can you can because
because if if the skin isn't firm enough
then to me that banana is like too far
gone
you know sometimes there's we've talked
about this there's a perfect amount of
ripeness that everyone loves with their
own bananas and I love it like this this
to me is like the perfect banana right
if if it's if the Skin's gone a bit too
soft uh if it's got like a bit of
Browning or like some spots are starting
then it's Swedish
as a kid I didn't understand how
ripeness worked I didn't understand why
my friend's house at his house his
bananas always tastes way better than
when my mum bought them and I realized I
was just eating them when they were
basically green
by the way this is this really looking
like a JoJo family screenshot